wie viele medikamente kann dieser
großhändler noch in zukunft liefern
130.000 präparate sind im lager
verfügbar
das unternehmen versorgt ganz
deutschland mit arzneimitteln
bedrohliche situation insofern also aus
meiner sicht jedenfalls das merken wir
moment auch gerade aktuell durch die
ausrufung der pandemie dass produkte
natürlich größtenteils wirkstoffe in
asien hergestellt werden in deutschland
ist die produktion auch weitestgehend
verschwunden
in europa ist auch die produktion weil
das kind verschwunden ist schon jetzt
klar dass einige wirkstoffe nicht mehr
produziert werden können in china werden
bei den produktionen ausgefallen ist in
wenigen monaten dürften so der
großhändler diese ausfälle auch in
deutschland zu spüren sein
das ist der nachteil der globalisierung
die globalisierung hat viele vorteile
aber das sind die klassischen nachteile
und wenn man dann noch unterschiedliche
staatsformen hat mit unterschiedlichen
interessenslagen dann kann es natürlich
passieren dass plötzlich ein land was
solche chancen genutzt hat
in eine machtposition reinkommt mit der
es nicht vernünftig umgeht und das ist
die politik das politische risiko was in
der globalisierung steckt deutschland
bezieht seine medikamente zum größten
teil aus indien und china
auch antibiotika 90 prozent der
weltweiten antibiotika produktion stammt
mittlerweile aus diesen beiden ländern
carla am im norden indiens die firma
citeq mediq er stieg zu einem wichtigen
player auf weil hier die löhne niedrig
sind und so kostengünstig medikamente
hergestellt werden
allerdings sind auch die inder abhängig
vom ausland fast die gesamte indische
pharmaindustrie ist auf lieferungen aus
china angewiesen für die eigene
produktion
wir sind total von china abhängig wenn
ich ihn ja keine rohstoffe mehr
exportiert werden 80 bis 90 prozent der
indischen pharmaproduzenten pleite gehen
im schlimmsten fall werden kranke
menschen sterben weil es zu wenig
medikamente gibt
indien bezieht seine wirkstoffe die
basis eines medikaments aus china weil
deren herstellung dort noch billiger ist
als in indien
in wenigen mega fabriken über den china
ein großteil des weltbedarfs an
wirkstoffen mittlerweile produziert quer
durch alle medikamentengruppen wie
konnte es zu dieser extremen
abhängigkeit ausgerechnet bei
arzneimitteln kommen die wichtigste
facette ist die dass wir seit zehn
jahren jetzt schon rabattverträge haben
oder sich dort sogar noch länger sind
glaube ich sogar 13 jahre rabattverträge
haben das heißt krankenkassen schließen
verträge mit herstellern vereinbaren
preise die preise natürlich dadurch sehr
stark gesunken
die krankenkassen lassen sich da auch
jahrelang schon für feiern dass die
kosten deutlich gesenkt haben positiver
effekt aber jetzt zeigt sich eben die
wirkung dass die ware womöglich gar
nicht mehr in ausreichender form nach
deutschland geliefert wird aufgrund der
produktionsausfälle infolge der chor
olap anämie gelange mittlerweile weniger
wirkstoffe nach indien
indien hat daher anfang märz den export
von 26 medikamenten eingeschränkt
darunter auch antibiotika so will die
regierung sicherstellen dass die eigene
bevölkerung noch mit genug arzneimitteln
versorgt werden kann
das könnte demnächst heißen dass auch
weniger nach deutschland exportiert wird
inzwischen wächst der druck sich aus
diesen abhängigkeiten zu lösen
das hat die politik inzwischen erkannt
im moment fehlt mir noch die fantasie
wie man dem preis erfolg dem erzielt hat
die preise sind runter wie man denen so
wieder anhebt dass die ware auch hier
produziert werden kann ohne dass nun
gleich wieder mit dem füllhorn das geld
ausgegeben werden muss die produktion
wieder in europa hoch zu ziehen würde
jahre dauern
in jedem fall müssten dafür die preise
für medikamente deutlich steigt